so you remember Sam Britton he was the
world famous MIT trained nuclear waste
disposal expert who ran the program for
Joe Biden when he's in court today he's
accused of stealing ladies underwear in
their luggage at a bunch of different
airports presumably wearing it it's not
weird by the way don't judge today it
was a preliminary hearing for stealing a
two thousand dollar bag from the airport
in Minneapolis Brenton's lawyers had
filed multiple requests for him to
attend the hearing remotely saying he's
having him we're quoting employment
issues he sure is the judge denied that
request but the judge did accommodate a
far more significant demand from Sam
Brenton who went along with Britain's
request to be called MX we're not going
to guess how to pronounce it MX Brinton
instead of Mr Brinton
so the bottom line is our gender fluid
nuclear waste expert friend may be going
to jail for up to five years and you may
not have a job but at least he's not
being misgendered subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube channel to catch our
nightly opens stories that are changing
the world and changing your life from
Tucker Carlson tonight